[Music]
donc
pour nous, c'est un défi parce que nous sommes
comme un pays désertique euh
sec donc ce que nous avons fait comme
vous savez ce que nous n'avons pas besoin de
tout faire sortir de l'extérieur, nous sommes
capables de le faire ici  doha
donc par des machines spéciales nous coupons un rouleau
d'environ 12 mètres sur
un mètre donc nous le roulons et nous
le déplaçons de l'autre côté
et la zone qui reste comme vous le voyez
ici vous pouvez voir que l'herbe travaille
à venir  de retour parce que les racines sont
là
[Musique]
nous sommes capables de construire quelque chose qui
vous montre l'étiquette
de l'héritage c'est quelque chose qui
restera après l'entraînement car
nous avons encore besoin de plus d'espace paysager pour être
[Musique  ]
planté
[Musique]
vous